everyone is warned and it's time to vote
on which theories you thought was the
best here's a recap of all of the
theories that one be sure to vote on
which one you thought was your favorite
at the end theory number four comes from
Gunther s and he has a theory that the
snap split the universe in two Gunther
said that the snap didn't kill everybody
it literally split the universe into the
dusted members all saw the opposite set
of characters get dusted as the two
universes were splitting apart which
means that there is now a universe where
the og Avengers were dusted but
spider-man and dr. strange are alive
during the snap the mine Stone gave fan
O's a how-to for a do-it-yourself
universe split the reality and space
stones were used to create the two
universes the soul stone was used to
ensure that everyone survived being
ripped into one universe or the other
the time stone was used to ensure that
everything was able to continue to
function without time being disrupted
the kicker is the Power Stone which
Gunter thinks they know used to split
himself into two as well and the
gauntlet and the stones that is why
Thanos is weakened and disoriented and
that is why the gauntlet was damaged
after the snap it's also why he will be
a totally crazy person an in-game
ant-man was protected by the snap from
being inside of the quantum realm which
he learns allows him to travel between
the two universes Scott goes to the
other universe to talk to Hank and Janna
to get the blueprints for the suits then
he goes back to our universe to get
everyone to work together to bring the
universes back together
that's why Thanos attacks that's why
everyone is marching together and that's
what the new suits are for and then when
the universe comes back together
that is what unlocks the dormant mutant
gene and the people who will become
x-men this is a pretty crazy theory but
it does have its merits after all Thanos
kept preaching mercy and salvation
throughout Avengers infinity war
eliminating half of the universe isn't
exactly a mercy or salvation so maybe
something else happened after all his
plan didn't really make sense he could
have just doubled the resources so
perhaps instead of killing everybody he
simply sent them into another universe
and the way Gunther lays out what each
individual infinity stone does does make
sense so perhaps we'll find out in
Avengers in game that there was a little
bit more to Thanos as planned than we
actually know comes from Zion the lion
and he has a theory about ant-man using
the time vortexes Zion says that
vengers endgame will start with ant-man
coming out of a time vortex because
ant-man suit is a prototype so he
probably can't get big so he goes out of
the time vortex at the last minute he
then ends up a little further in the
future about three weeks to a month
after the snap but Iron Man and nebula
come back to earth about the same time
when ant-man comes out of the quantum
realm but soon after thinness comes to
attack the Avengers and almost kills all
of them because Thanos gets a vision of
himself dying from Captain America or
Hulk wildung the gauntlet along with the
other Avengers standing in front of him
it's in the scene in the new trailer
where Thor Captain America and Iron Man
are walking up to Thanos Thanos ends up
defeating them but ant-man has his van
at the Avengers facility and goes back
into the quantum realm before he dies he
goes back inside of the quantum realm
and he finds that quantum city and
inside of the quantum city he finds dr.
strange dr. strange will tell ant-man
which time vortex to go through that
will cause their one winning scenario to
happen and at the same time this will
create the multiverse this theory could
work because I think it's a very
different play on time-travel than we
all think I think most of the people
think that the Avengers will go fight
Thanos and he'll defeat them and they'll
go back to earth
but why would daños leave the Avengers
alive if he knows they're trying to undo
his plan so if Thanos attacks the
Avengers at their headquarters and is
killing the Avengers it would make sense
that a man would go back into the
quantum realm to try and go back in time
before Thanos attacks and I do think
Doctor Strange is still going to be
guiding somebody in Avengers in game to
help them go to that once an area where
they win he is the master of the mystic
arts and it has been mentioned lately
that perhaps everybody that has been
dusted is actually in Soul world and
perhaps the way to get there is through
the quantum realm so perhaps we could
see this theory come to light in
Avengers in game theory number three
comes from Cameron Valentine who has a
theory about Thor in Avengers in game
Cameron says that so far and all of the
TV spot trailers Thor isn't shown too
much and only has two lines the two of
them being I saw all those people die
and I like this one of course referring
to Captain Marvel throughout all the
trailers he seems lost and thought and
traumatized by all the deaths that he
feels responsible for for not going for
the head and we now know that some time
passes in Avengers in game maybe even a
couple of years and we know that Thor is
very emotion
and highly driven by impulse so after
all this time passes Thor probably wants
to go and fight they anis to get a
second chance but doesn't know if it's
the right decision or not so he starts
to have differences with the Avengers
and ultimately decides that he needs to
go find and fight Thanos and then
Captain Marvel has to stop him she's the
only one who's strong enough to actually
be able to stop him this is why Thor and
Captain Marvel are missing in all of the
TV spots and trailers in the scene where
all of the Avengers are wearing their
white suits Thor and Captain Marvel have
gone off together and will most likely
form a bond after all Thor and Captain
Marvel are both extremely powerful and
emotional beans that have dealt with a
lot and the line I saw all those people
died could be Thor talking to Captain
Marvel he could be explaining everything
that has happened to him his brother
turning into evil his entire family's
death the destruction of Asgard and then
Thanos snapping away half of the people
in existence this theory does make sense
because if Thor is feeling remorse and
guilt which we know that he is and he
wants to go off and fight Thanos again
by himself Captain Marvel is the only
person who could stop him and they
aren't in the scenes and not just the
white suit scene Thor and Captain Marvel
really aren't in any scenes besides the
very beginning besides the scene where
all of them are in the Bennet are going
to space but this would take place after
that so Thor not being able to deal with
the feet wanting to go after Thanos
again and Captain Marvel trying to stop
him could happen in Avengers end game so
that's it for theory number
[Music]
[Music]